dear president now zaida Rector organis
Mrs vietkin
friends and distinguished guests
this past year counters has been one big
stage for Europe a European capital of
culture
a stage bustling with creativity
diversity and positive energy
your program included over 4 000 artists
60 exhibitions
and over 250 concerts
you have opened a creative space which
gives shelter to Ukrainian artists and
Families
you have opened the door not just to art
but to people
their free ideas and to Healing
at a time when War has sadly returned to
our continent
counters has welcomed over 13 000
Ukrainian refugees
so with all my heart I can only say
thank you thank you for sharing with us
your community's Deep Roots and
resilience
and for inspiring solidarity across our
Union
for this was not a European capital of
culture year like any other
you understand better than most the
value and the power of Art
modernism helped counters reimagine the
identity
of a newly independent Lithuania 100
years ago
and your city has again showed how art
can be used in the fight for freedom
while Putin's War has closed the door to
cultural venues in Ukraine you opened
culture in Ukraine
Center for Public debate cultural
exchange and art therapy
it protects
and projects Ukrainian voices
so together we can reaffirm what it
means to be European today
that is the main topic of your Symposium
the idea of Europe
an idea that was born roughly 25 Century
ago in Greece
for ancient Greeks
Europe wasn't just a geographic term
it meant freedom
democracy
and the power in the hands of free
citizens
the absence of autocracy
today the idea of Europe has gone back
to its Origins
and joining Europe
has become synonymous
with reclaiming your country's
sovereignty against foreign oppression
yes Russia is trying to take us back in
time
but those who have struggled to be free
will not accept the bondages of an
uglier past
the European Union and our member states
have already supported Ukraine with
almost 20 billion euros
and this does not include our military
assistance
is the world's second largest
humanitarian donor to Ukraine per capita
from a small country like yours comes a
great example
for our entire Union we are so grateful
for this
we will continue to stand by Ukraine
because ukrainians are fighting for Hope
in a better future a European future
the same way your city and your nation
have struggled to be free
I wish you a wonderful discussion
Long Live Europe thank you